yesterday I told you about Donald Trump
jr. often known as the slightly less
dumb Donald Trump son telling Sean
Hannity that the Biden's are bad because
hunter Biden got a consulting gig a
board position as someone corrected me
yesterday just because his last name is
Biden because he's the son of a former
vice president and the irony was lost
either on Don jr. himself or on his
followers who maybe are just too
ignorant to figure out the absurdity of
Don jr. criticizing someone else for
nepotism we talked about that yesterday
Eric Trump now traditionally known as
the dumb one is jumping on the same
bandwagon and saying essentially the
same thing
Eric Trump over the weekend was on that
crazy fox news show hosted by wacky
judge Jeanine Pirro and Eric trump told
Jeanine Pirro that it is just sickening
that's his word when families use power
Fame and money to further enrich
themselves can barely get through it it
seems that in the same way that Donald
Trump completely lacks a sense of humor
the Trump children were born without an
ability for self-awareness let's take a
look at the clip they're fighting all of
this yet they have a candidate that lies
about being a Cherokee Indian when she's
one one-thousandth and twenty-fourth
Cherokee you have a guy whose son is
embezzling money from everybody and
enriching himself off of the you know
his father's position under so then
where does Joe Biden get off being so
pompous and above it all well you know I
think American people are going to see
that he is pompous and they are above it
all and if I was doing the same thing
that that family was doing I'd be in
jail like that's right why is it that
every family goes into politics and
enriches themselves we're the only
family yes at least money he stopped
doing deals and my father became a
businessman we were visited we are
business people we stopped doing deals
when he went into politics and rich in
himself off of his father's position can
you imagine being Eric Trump and saying
that on national television and being
this out of touch can you understand the
level at which you are completely
clueless when you go on television and
say things like this
never mind by the way I mean it's like
obviously he's lying through his teeth
his family stopped doing deal
when Trump became president that's an
obvious lie he says if I were doing the
same things that the Biden's did I'd be
in prison you're doing way worse and at
least your dad should be in prison what
a total lack of an ability to identify
double standards and hypocrisy and irony
and by the way I'm sure that as wacky as
judge Jeanine Pirro is I guarantee you
that she understands how absurd it is
for Eric Trump to be on television
saying that families that self enrich
are sickening but of course she's a
trump brown-noser she's a role player
and she's not going to say a word about
it because that would be stepping out of
the role that she plays so at least for
now
I do still think that Donald Trump that
Eric Trump qualifies as the dumbest
Trump kid alive I know we're not
supposed to talk about the ones that are
underage I have no idea about their
intelligence either according to what
Donald Trump has said about what Barron
can do with computers it certainly
sounds like Barron is smarter than Eric
now to go back to the earlier thing
about how Trump likes to say that the
presidency has cost him money that he's
ended conflicts of interest eric says
that they've stopped doing deals it's
basically all lies with one exception
the exception being that it is probable
that the presidency has so stained the
Trump brand with many many people that
there are more and more individuals and
businesses that want nothing to do with
anything named Trump but those losses
have obviously been counteracted with
everything from foreign leaders staying
at Donald Trump's hotels in order to
ingratiate themselves with him funneling
money from their governments directly
into Trump's pocket to Trump having
hundreds of golf trips to his own golf
clubs which is another transfer of money
from the government to his private
businesses as Secret Service and
everybody else stays at Trump's own
resorts so there may be some way in
which there has been some loss to
Trump's brand's value as a result of the
presidency and Trump's staining of the
name but it is a drop in the bucket
compared
the amount of money that has been
funneled directly into Trump and his
family's bank accounts by foreign
governments and by our own government
that's a really important thing to
understand it's not just foreign
governments that are enriching Trump it
is our own that is doing the same thing
not exactly draining the swamp as Donald
Trump promised to do